Speaker 1: Welcome back to the David Pakman
show.
I am Farron Cousins from Ring of Fire, sitting
in for David once again today.
You know, we've already talked a lot about
Donald Trump, the documents, Mar a Lago, the
investigation and all that.
And I don't want to continue talking about
that, even though that is dominating the news,
making it harder to find any stories.
But there's one more thing I got to talk.
Speaker 2: About with it.
Speaker 1: And that one more thing.
Speaker 2: Is trump's son donald trump jr.
On Monday.
Speaker 1: Donald Trump.
Speaker 2: Jr.
Speaker 1: Came down to my city of Pensacola,
Florida, to campaign, of course, for Republican
candidate Matt Gaetz, which Gates didn't really
need it.
He was going to win the.
Speaker 2: Primary easily.
Speaker 1: But.
Junior comes down, brings Kimberly GUILFOYLE
with him.
They do an event.
And it was during this event that Junior started
talking about the the investigation into the
documents and all that stuff stored down there
at Mar a Lago.
And Junior not only defended his father, but
said that if he had, you know what, I'm not
going to give it away.
I'm going to read the quote.
This is what Donald Trump Junior said in Pensacola,
Florida, on Monday, by the way, for the record,
which.
Okay, you don't have to put both of those
qualifiers in there.
You would either say, by the way, or for the
record.
But you don't need to say.
By the way, for the record.
Speaker 2: Just a little grammar lesson there
for everybody.
Speaker 1: By the way.
For the record, I'd say that if Donald Trump
actually still had the nuclear codes, it'd
probably be good.
Our enemies might actually be like, okay,
maybe let's not mess with them.
Unlike when they look at Joe Biden and they
say, You know what?
We should attack now.
See, I was unaware.
And maybe it's because of my sleepy little
town.
But I was unaware that foreign leaders were
actually out there saying, Let's go attack
America right now.
Have there been attacks like does it happen
while I'm sleeping in the.
Nobody tweets about it, so I don't see it
the next day.
Or.
Or is he just making stuff up because he's
a moron?
Speaker 2: I'm going to go with the latter
on that one, by the way.
Speaker 1: Here's the other part of his incredibly
stupid statement.
If Donald Trump still had nuclear codes in
those documents, well, guess what?
They would no longer be valid.
I can promise you, they've probably changed
the codes multiple times since Donald Trump
left office.
But even assuming they hadn't.
Right.
Let's indulge Jr's little fantasy here.
Assuming they had not changed the nuclear
codes and Donald Trump did have them.
He still couldn't issue a nuclear strike.
And the rest of the world knows that.
Because he's not the president of the United
States.
Does Junior think that anybody with those
nuclear codes is just able to order a nuclear
strike?
I mean, I guess if you did a good enough,
you know, Biden impression and you had the
nuclear code, you you might be able to do
something like that.
But just having the codes in and of themselves
doesn't give you the authority.
To launch nuclear weapons.
So again, not 100% sure exactly what Junior
is trying to tell us here.
But I can tell you that everything he says
is completely false.
Like one, we don't have world leaders sitting
around like, oh, Trump's going, great, let's
go fired missiles at America.
Because apparently what Trump took the entire
military with him is, is it just gone now?
Like we didn't just give them $800 billion
for the next 12 months.
Did I make all that up?
Was that all just a fever dream that I had?
No.
The military is still there.
We still have all the weapons that we had
when Trump was there, if not more at.
Speaker 2: This point, obviously, because
we just picked more up.
Speaker 1: Every year.
So, yeah, the rest of the world still knows
that no matter who is in charge of the White
House, we can still do some pretty significant
damage to them if they were to come over here
and attack us.
So no matter which way you slice Jaws, little
weird fantasy there of trying to defend his
father's behavior.
It makes no sense.
And trust me, I've been trying to make sense
of it for quite some time.
And dang it.
Speaker 2: I simply cannot
do it.